what is going on everybody welcome to
part 4 of our Python with PI QT tutorial
video series in this video we're going
to be talking about having custom
methods or functions when you go to
click your buttons so custom event
handling so the first thing we need to
do is let's go ahead and create the
method that we want to use when we click
a button so you can put this method
really anywhere within our window class
but I think it's best to have you like
you're you're in it obviously at the top
then maybe your views and then your
methods below you might also a lot of
people get angry because I write
everything in one script you might also
have another script for you know methods
that you might run or something like
that but until an application gets to
like over a thousand lines I really
think it's unnecessary to make a bunch
of extra files but do what you want so
define and this one's gonna be define
clothes underscore application and again
you have self now then we're gonna go
print and then we'll just say whoa so
custom and then we'll just run a simple
sistex --it and that should that should
close i close it for everybody there now
then we come here in button click got
connect we can replace this here with
self dot close on our score application
now when we go to run this we can click
quit and then not only did it quit but
we also got our whoa so custom message
now I understand you're probably like
well we already had something that could
quit stupid you something like that and
really like closing an application or
quitting is like the easiest thing to
code besides like maybe a print function
but we also want to show that we can do
stuff with the application we could also
do other things you know you could say
something like this so exit you cuz you
can leave print or you know wow so
custom movie view set window title pie
QT Tut's with more exclamation points
should be able to get away with this
we'll see
quit and then yeah so you can see that
we got more exclamation points and so
that's really just a quick example but
it's good enough to show that you can
start modifying the window with these
methods you don't necessarily have to
quit or something like that but we're
going to leave this quit and we'll
actually build up this quit more as time
goes on but anyways that's the quit and
now the only other thing I want to show
you guys before we move on and is going
to be we're going to come down to this
button definition here and there's a
couple of things that are kind of built
in to QT which are kind of nice so you
have button resize and button move
you can leave button move alone but
resize if you recall there was a default
size right so if we ran this without
specifying any size tour button that's
the size and in fact let's put at zero
zero so we can use we can use the title
as a point of reference so as you can
see that's a pretty big button and it
goes past the the window title now we
can also do a button resize 100/100 okay
so that's now at the top corner and then
we can also put in a different parameter
here we can say button and we're gonna
say the size we want it to be as BTN dot
size hint okay
so what this is going to do is it's
going to pack the QT is going to give us
sort of a hint at what size maybe we
ought to use and this is an accordance
to how much space is there how many
other buttons we have and so on and it
might behoove you to use size hint on
all of your buttons just so you can have
some you know some sort of automated
structure now so when we run size hint
you can see we're actually returned a
pretty small button and it doesn't quite
go past or it might but it would be
slight if it did the title but it's much
smaller so you've got size hamp and then
you've also got another one which is a
minimum size hint and that will return
the smallest suggested sighs so sighs
hint will return just like the best it
thinks and then you can also pass in
minimum size so to return to you like
the smallest it thinks is also
acceptable now as we can see this return
basically the same thing this is not
much difference here but you just can
know that these two things exist so we
can leave uh I'm just gonna leave it at
100 whoa I can't decide what I want well
we'll leave minimum sizing that's
totally fine it doesn't really matter
what we do with this button you can do
what you want as well so anyways that's
that with this application and buttons
and doing your own little custom methods
don't worry we will build up our own
custom methods to be a little cooler
than what this one is doing but I think
it's good to start with the basics first
at least keeping things basic so it's
easy to understand how simple this
connection really is now in the next
video we're going to be talking about is
adding a main menu to our window because
that's something pretty much everybody
wants so that's what we're going to be
talking about in the next video if you
have any questions or comments up to
this point please feel free to leave
them below otherwise as always thanks
for watching things for all the
supported subscriptions and until next
time